power scripts pitch today in Hollywood
either one of you well um you know it's
a very different world now because the
big studios they make less than they
used to and what they seem to make are
sequels or you know the Marvel world of
comics action you know it used to be
that there was a large open category of
what they call rom-coms and you know
just that didn't exist anymore and
that's why and you know it's funny the
flow when I got to Hollywood TV was so
dull and stupid you know in sitcom which
is what i wrote to come you know it's
just like one stupid joke after another
now TV is where all the excitement is in
terms of writers and you know the
writing on some of the television shows
is so like you know bad and breaking bad
and like even house you know which is an
older show but it's just some blown away
with television quality like the psycho
one I forget the name of it it's coming
back you know about the kid when he went
when psycho kid was young you know
whatever that thing it's wonderful and
films are now you know they got to be
the big tentpole so I I don't know I
just don't finished a movie that was a
rare one because it's a small dance
musical that that is based on a true
story of a man whose career I followed
and who's become a good friend he
created this event called carnival which
is a choreographers ball down on he'd be
great for you'd interview because he's
phenomenal he created this he came from
a rough rough rough background and he
all your North Hollywood his dad's like
I heroin you know I mean a Hells Angel
guy and his moms like a meth addict kind
of crap and but he he discovered dance
and he created something that's the only
one in the world which is about
choreographers and it's a longer thing
he can tell you but that was an unusual
thing to pitch that and you know have it
sell but CBS films you know is headed by
les Moonves who's very inventive and you
know he he's one of a kind you know what
he did with CBS and then he went out to
do the film thing so we were able to
sell it there and very small movie and
but there's not that many places that
are open to small movies you know when I
say small that means like not a big
leading star you know with you know on a
horse or something you know what I mean
and I don't you know it's so it's a
different world out there
you